the two on the left are Jonah Jonah and
the Whale so the story of Jonah is an
interesting one oh I'll just go over it
very briefly there's a city and the city
is full of people who are sinful what
does that mean well to sin is an archery
term it means to miss the mark so these
are people who aren't oriented properly
and so the city is in a chaotic state
and God tells Jonah that he's going to
go to that city and tell them just
exactly what's up with them and Jonah
thinks no I'm not going to do that and
why well
that doesn't require much explanation
it's like how popular are you going to
be if you go to a city full of chaotic
people and tell them why they're stupid
didn't wrong it's Jonah thinks no I'm
not going to do that I don't care if
God's telling me to do it so it's
conscience is telling him to do it or
his destiny is telling him to do it or
or his orientation with higher morality
is telling them to do it you can read it
any way you want and so he thinks no I'm
hopping on this boat and I'm getting as
far away from that city as I possibly
can and so he does that and then the
storm comes up because God thinks no
you're not getting away if I told you to
do something you're not getting away
from it a storm comes up well what does
that mean well it's easy betray your
destiny and see how long it takes you to
be drowning in the storm it will happen
immediately and of course it will
because what what's calling you to be
your best is exactly the thing that's
pushing you forward to manifest yourself
most fully in the world it's what you
need you run away from that the boats
going to start to rock very very quickly
well you all know that you / you know
that perfectly well it's how all you
have to do is not study for an exam that
you know that's coming up to see
everything start to the storm water
start to rise and everything start to
rock it's pretty bloody obvious so
anyways he's on this boat and there's a
storm and all of the people on the boat
who can't quite discriminate chaos from
weather because they haven't
differentiated the world to that degree
think oh the boat wouldn't be about to
be swamped if we had
some of us had done something stupid and
wrong and there's logic in that you know
you might think well God has nothing
personal against you because of the
storm so you're confusing levels of
analysis but you got to give these
people some credit it's like maybe they
did do something stupid
maybe they didn't caulk the damn boat
properly maybe the ropes aren't in as
good a shape as they might be maybe they
weren't paying attention to the weather
when they went out on the ocean you know
or maybe they haven't made peace with
their brother and so their hearts are
bent twisted out of shape so they don't
make particularly good sailors it's like
the idea that you encounter a storm
because you're stupid and wrong is a
really good idea even though it's not of
infinite applicability anyways they draw
a lot it's a primitive thing to do it's
like well it's one is someone's fault we
don't know who we're going to throw
someone overboard the worst sinner
obviously that's what God wants some
kind of sacrifice so they all draw lots
and someone loses and then Jonah stands
up and says well sorry guys like I know
that I've got a problem with God at the
moment so it's probably me you better
throw me over and they don't really want
to but he finally convinces them over he
goes and the storm settles well you know
sometimes if you're in a group of people
in an organization there is someone in
the organization whose head isn't
screwed on exactly straight and they
know exactly why it is and what they've
done wrong and what puts them in that
position and they are poisoning the
entire enterprise and if you throw them
overboard or better if they agree
voluntarily to leave then the storm will
abate and everything will be okay
certainly ways they throw Joe Joe over
or Jonah overboard and a whale comes up
and swallows them and takes them down to
the bottom of the ocean well we already
know what that means because we watched
Pinocchio it's like when God abandons
you because you've abandoned your
destiny and the storms come up the
probability that you're going to be
taken down to the to the depths is
extraordinarily high and that happens in
people's lives all the time also down
there Jonah repents well what do you do
when you in the underworld you've been
there before when things fall apart on
your friends have abandoned you you're
not as popular as you could be you can't
stand to look at yourself in the mirror
into the underworld you
oh and you think geez I've done a lot of
things wrong you know maybe I should
reconcile myself with the world and I
could get out of this well so that's
what Jonah does he thinks all right I've
got this destiny
I better go do what God says so the
Whale spits them out onto the beach and
off he goes to the city to tell them
what's wrong well that's what that
represents that's these symbols you know
it's so cool this second one I really I
really like it's so interesting because
you see Joan re-emerging from the whale
and he's got a halo around his head you
say well what's a halo well have you
ever looked at a quarter well think
about a quarter a quarter is the moon
and who's on the quarter the Queen the
Queen is surrounded by the halo of the
moon the Queen's queen of the queen of
the night gold coin that's the king's
head on the Sun that's the halo well
what comes out of the belly of the of
the fish it's the illuminated human
being it's the spirit of the illuminated
human being well that's what that means
well what does that mean well what else
would come out of chaos you know if you
if you fall apart and then you put
yourself back together what is it that
comes back out at least you're in better
shape than you were before you know and
and then maybe you do that 20 times in
your life or 50 times and you do it
voluntarily every time you do it you're
more like the thing with the halo and
less like the thing that's you know
being thrown overboard by your friends